what's the greatest thing about being a
mom everything
i mean absolutely everything you know
it's very early mornings
but i am so excited every morning it's
like christmas
nya rivera's family is keeping her
memory alive for her four-year-old son
josie thursday marks one month since the
lakely star's body was found in
lake piru california after she went
missing on july 8
following a boat ride with her son there
are a lot of currents
on the lake the idea perhaps being that
the boat started drifting it was
unanchored
and that she mustered enough energy to
get her son back onto the boat
but not enough to save herself now a
source tells et that while this has been
a difficult time for her family and
loved ones
the actress's son is quote doing better
every day
according to the source josie is with
his father ryan dorsey full time
and adds that nya's sister nikayla is
very involved
and spends a lot of time with her nephew
you love being a mommy oh my gosh yes
the source also shares that josie
understands that his mom is gone
and that he grasps the finality of death
but the source says that ryan who was
married to naya from 2014 to 2018
is having a tougher time but is staying
strong for his little one
i always kept a plane for him he was
just uh he was kind of always the one
quote
ryan's whole world is josie right now
ryan is still grieving
and is very much struggling with the
loss of naya
but he stays strong and keeps going for
the sake of his son
the source adds that ryan has always
been a very involved father
and would do anything for his son
right now he's really laying low and
staying out of the public eye
so he can completely focus on josie and
try to figure out how to navigate this
new normal
according to the source ryan and josie
talk about nya
every day and the family wants to make
sure that he has good memories of his
mom
and that she remains a big part of his
life
you know i'm a mom now and i you know
what i love more than acting
is being josie's mom so i want to be
here for him
and i don't want to miss anything and
while there's still a lot of tough times
we're told that there's also a lot of
laughter
and lightness josie is a very strong boy
and naya would be very proud of him